what I decided to do I want to show you
some different openings so it will be
mixture of studying many different
openings and at the end we'll also do
some endgame work okay so today I won't
be just showing you one game I will
showing you many different openings so
you can pick that you know what you want
to play maybe you will like something
and you can ask some questions okay so
the first opening I want to show you is
the D for us white okay what to play
when opponent plays this move is six
first of all please raise your hand if
you know which opening now black is
trying to play here yes Queen's Gambit
then we have two Queens gambit declined
okay declined okay so that's a Queens
gambit declined opening it says decline
because he's not accepting it okay
because if it takes that would be
accepted okay alright so now he plays
declined now 93 Knight f6 first we're
going to look at the move Knight f6
because this is the most popular move
and then we're going to look at the move
Bishop e7 as well
okay so Knight f6 again I'm showing this
for a white side okay so you take CTX d5
because it's important to take here
right away because you don't want this
part to be hanging okay and you kind of
want to have a fixed structure so you
know what kind of structure you're going
to have here so you take okay there are
two type of possibilities here he can
take backward upon or he can take back
with a knight okay if he takes back with
a pawn that's the main move taking well
with the knight it's it's a playable
move but white is slightly better after
e4 because after captured or white is
the control of the center so here's just
slightly better okay but now takes
Bishop to g5 pinning the night now if he
plays this move this is bad move if it
just does something like this what you
going to do take the knight if it takes
back and you'll have a terrible pawn
structure very bad and if it takes with
the Queen we pick up the central pawn
okay so remember we go Bishop g5 pinning
him and creating a threat but now there
is a trap here let's see if you know
this trap if it goes here now can you
take the pawn on d5 question is it looks
like a pin right it looks like a
relative pin you take on d5 and he
cannot take back because we win his
queen this is a pin right a relative pin
and if my question is can you take this
pawn would that be a good move here
no okay why Knight takes Knight look at
this line we should takes Queen Bishop
check absolutely he has to give up the
Queen I've seen so many just tears fall
for this job
he takes check and guess what at the end
he just picks it up got it he just picks
it up everybody understand this let's go
back and do this again because I want to
make sure everyone here knows this and
they never never fall for this trap okay
d4 d5 c4 e6 as soon as he plays even if
somebody asks you here what is the name
of door opening what you should say now
at this point do you do you know okay
well it's the answer is undecided we
don't know yet after the second move we
would know which opening is this okay so
we don't know the opening yet because
there could be three four or five
different openings let's see how many
different openings now black can play
from here on so once we did this one is
six it's very important for you to know
a lot of these names and at least couple
the moves of all the openings you don't
necessarily have to play them but just
knowledge will make you better player
and more comfortable okay like I play a
couple of openings but I know most of
the lines in the names it makes you feel
more comfortable okay and if you know
ideas from one opening you can sometimes
using another opening okay so Queen's
gonna be the climb what will be another
choice here for black yes
c6 this will be which opening slab
defense
next there are at least couple of more
opening choices here
96 I don't know if that's a particular
opening here but there's couple of more
capital we already did this right D
takes e4 we talk about Queen's Gambit
exhibit already three right the client
accepted Slav but they're couple more
yes please
excellent and what is this one she
Gordon she go in Russian grandmasters
should go in okay this is also very
tricky you have to know it it's not a
very common opening choice but it was
played with by Russian grandmas and
Milosevic when I think he played against
Kasparov even so he wasn't afraid to
play against even you know the best
player so we have four there is two more
here two more openings c5 it's it may
have a name but it's very unorthodox and
not so good yeah there might be an MS
please aha Bishop is called Baltic okay
this is the Baltic okay yeah I have a
friend he's about 2200 he likes to play
this opening a lot so this is his
opening anybody plays he goes to the
Baltic sir yeah
the Baltic yeah well very tricky very
tricky because if you don't know what to
do it's you know so what I'll be doing
I'll be showing you a little bit of how
to play against this openings okay but
first we are working on the Queen's
Gambit and the last one and who can find
a last opening he can play here that's
five or six already
we have one more the last one it's a
gambit 'if I've and this opening is cold
yeah it's not [ __ ] they're all been all
being gambit okay in total there about
10 to 12 openings the most they can play
against d4 okay so we just learn the six
of them already okay
that the first few moves but okay we are
working on this one
c6 93 so you take he takes and remember
you go Bishop g5 and here you don't take
on d5 okay you don't take on d5 okay
because it's a trap
okay everybody understand how the trap
works don't take you play III now when
you play e3 you are threatening again
it's like you renewing the same threat
now because now you have an escape
square for the King to go to okay now I
go c6 Bishop d3 Bishop e7 and now most
of the players play Knight f3 here but
that's not what I'm going to recommend
for you and I recommend for you this set
up with 9g - this was played by a world
champion Petrosyan and also Kasparov
played a couple of times as well okay so
this is a little bit more active setup
and you will see the reason castles
Queen c2 this is your set up remember
Bishop is supposed to be on g5 Bishop on
the T 90 years this is your setup if
anybody plays the Queens gambit declined
okay this is your setup now he goes here
you castle
and now normally in this kind of
positions when you have a knight on f3
the way that you play here is you go
route B 1 and B 4 okay
you start this minority attack idea this
is the most common way to play do a
minority attack okay but with the night
only two you're not going for minority
you're going for the central attack in
the center now you want to play a 4 and
E 5 and start attacking in the center ok
this is how I play if somebody play's
this opening now the point is you want
to play you for if you had put the
knight on f3 day you cannot play for so
you understand why we do this now he
goes Knight g6 and now rook 81 by the
way this is a game of a cusp out of here
cause part of Peru WA from 2000 a spot
always white against Indian Grandmaster
bar WA so if you want to search this
game so you can find it on chess games
and many websites and chest base of
course if you have Kasparov is white
against parwa so now please do KD 1 you
can ask me why why do you play this now
right but there is an idea behind it you
want to have it the center protected
here ok because you're ready to push
efore and when you push before you want
that rook to be on d1 ok so it goes h6
Bishop takes f6 Bishop takes f6 Bishop
takes g6 we just give up our two knights
and now the move is efore we can take
this pump but we don't want to do that
that would be a mistake because if you
take this one is going to take this one
okay if you take that one he is going to
take that one ok so you pay a fortune
and now if it takes you take now do you
see he has one too if you didn't have
your rope here you see what would have
happened he would have pick up your pawn
on d4 and say check okay here we go pick
up your pawn and say check so you will
find yourself in trouble okay so you
don't want that to happen that's why you
play rook a d1 that's the real reason
behind it so now I place g5
now when the pawn is only for your next
idea is to play e5 to push you're
pushing back now he goes here f4
now attacking on g5 now he takes night
xf4
and now as you can see white is very
active here there is a weak Square on g6
for him to go to so it goes rook f8 and
now plant the 19 on g6 he takes take
Bishop e6 and now we reach this position
now what is the best move here for why
what should be the next one here what
should be the next pawn here for white
what should be the next idea here huh
spend some time spend some time well but
where are you going to go yeah yes okay
but then it takes my night is actually
better than the bishop at this moment
and also I'm it's very likely I can take
this later too so I'm not even hard to
take this I would look at it and see
what piece mm-hmm nah see four excellent
I want him so excellent suggestion
excellent that's what caused part of
plate 92 very good playing like a spot
of and hon if you do it more often
then you're going to see a lot of lot of
wins anyway the idea is absolutely you
point out exactly what we needed to do
here if you look at the position our
night is perfect
queeny's is you know more or less okay
here
rookies on a bed square possibly can be
but what is the knight doing here and
this is the question you have to ask
yourself do you do you do that like when
you're playing a game do you sometimes
look at your pieces and see that which
piece is doing anything or you always
have to try to find the piece that is
not doing anything and try to improve it
okay that's the key to have better
better results to see if you can improve
okay
the pieces so you go here now it goes
here and now what is the idea here
it looks like if we go here he has this
but does this really work
does this really work
aha but okay which one is the best move
here which move take with the Queen yes
Queen takes f5 because when he takes
back we go 97 check and the King moves
away we pick it up alright excellent
position okay two extra nights and a
passed pawn on an e file is going
through excellent alright now I want to
go back and review this okay with you
because okay most likely he's not going
to play Bishop f5 okay he's not gonna
die he's going to play something like
this but here I would recommend
eliminating this Bishop and you play
this position very comfortable advantage
for white okay because you have this
excellent night that is sitting on g6 he
cannot remove it you can you can have
some ideas like g3 King G to h4 h5 to
plant this knight in here so it's just a
comfortable position it's not like
you're winning you slightly better here
but very comfortable okay so we're going
to go back and review this okay with you
and I want you to reach this position
okay so all right okay so we're going to
start from here so go ahead
you play the moves for white first move
d4 d5 please excellent six
now next Knight c3 okay you want to go
next okay you will be next go ahead now
what's the move here 9390 f6 remember we
are trying to get a fixed structure okay
we don't want it to take us and you know
the structure is we have to think about
him doing that okay we don't want that
so what do we do now to avoid this
because he wants to take it right so you
try to take it okay
you try to take it now he takes back and
now what is the next move now go ahead
yes
aha Bishop g5 pinning the knight very
good and now threatening to take it now
he goes here the question is now can we
take on d5 no because of the trap
okay remember the trap everybody
remembers the trap here okay great so
what is the correct move we cannot take
right we know that III of course of
course natural in openings you play
natural moves okay it's most of the time
if you're going to make a unnatural type
of move in opening its dubious move okay
most of the opening moves should be
natural looking moves okay most of the
time now he goes here c6 and now okay
Bishop d3 and next move for white
black plays here in 2-seater it doesn't
matter you can start with Queenie to
Quincy to an IG - it is absolutely no
difference here okay I did this but it
doesn't matter and next one we go Quincy
- okay so we reach this position now he
Castle he goes here now King is in the
middle where we going to do
castle now he goes back here and now no
more minority attack because with the
night only two minority attack is not
effective because you need a knight on
f3 if you're going to do minority attack
okay again minority tech when you push
the pants on the Queen side here you go
for the other plan and which plan is it
they have to be yes excellent f3 the
idea to play E for when you play this
setup if your opponent doesn't notice
he's going to feel very uncomfortable
okay I played this position against
grandmasters and you know they didn't
know exactly what to do and it could be
it could be a trouble okay because you
know exactly what you need to do that's
a good thing you play f3 you're going to
play e4 your plan is very clear and
having a clear plan is a big advantage
in opening and middle game stages
because for black he's trying to see
okay how can I try to defend against
this plan yeah
because obviously black cannot attack
here he is on defense here and that's
where you want to be it you put pressure
black is defending 96 and now here we
are not rushing to play efore okay we
are not rushing so which move we have to
play here first
yes route 81 purpose why we do that move
absolutely yes because all so that's the
only piece that is sitting here in the
corner right that's the only piece looks
like your your your other pieces are in
the game all your other pieces are in
the game this is the one that is sitting
- so we all wanted to be that we want in
the game when we start the attack now he
goes h6 questioning your bishop
and now what do you do here yes Bishop
takes f6 correct Bishop takes f6 next
now you give up your bishop you better
have a good plan yeah because bishops
are more valuable a little bit more
valuable than the Knights so what is the
idea now no yes g6 you take the other
night
you take one night then you take the
other night you're given week pawns
perfect now the question is what do we
do now yes now it's time to e4 and if it
takes us you see the reason why I put we
put the rook on d1 right so we don't
have that pawn on d4 hanging okay so
every move in the opening should have a
purpose okay should have a purpose why
you play the move okay we all never just
make moves it has to be an ID behind it
the purpose got it
perfect
so I played g5 now continue couple of
more moves needed yes pushed upon right
that's your goal remember when you play
f3 for your goal is to play e5 ok
everybody understand that idea you play
f3 for you want to play e5 that's what
you're trying to do it goes back here
and now what's next
perfect opening up the line right we
have a row Conair file we don't want
that F file to be closed right by
playing f4 we're going to allow our look
to get even more active takes
and now there is a weak square when you
see a weak square yeah your knife can
jump into the squares you go for it
right that's why there is if the palm
was on eight seven the evaluation of
this position would have been completely
different
if this pawn is on h7 black is
absolutely fine absolutely fine okay
probably not better but at least equal
and in fact in a long run when the
pieces come off the board he has two
bishops this is two nights he will be
better because having the two bishops
versus two nights in the endgame would
be a pretty good advantage for him but
that one pawn makes a big difference
okay because the g6 square is available
for your knight
so we go in you check we take back it
goes here this is a crucial moment
realizing that one of your pieces on our
Europe is not developed that well and
it's not doing so much it and you try to
improve it okay and in this particular
position that piece is knight on c3
correct and what do we do with the night
very good
e to Queen d7 I have four that's it
clear advantage here and if he plays
Bishop a5 this is a blunder but I was
just showing you you know this is a
blunder what do you do take with a queen
perfect he takes back for Kim for Kim
and win it excellent job okay so he
cannot do anything okay so remember that
he cannot do anything okay
all right next we're going to look at
another idea
for black now if black doesn't want to
allow this system he can actually do
that if he can actually prevent you from
playing this setup okay by starting with
the move Bishop e7 because when he does
this obviously you cannot go Bishop g5
because he'll just take you and if you
play Knight f3
then he transposes to the normal Queen's
Gambit a client but remember we want to
have a night only - we don't want to
have the night only three so a lot of
people to avoid this they go Bishop e7
including me if I decide to play this I
play this sometimes if I play the qgd
who is gamma the client they play the
setup I go Bishop e7 here because I
don't want to allow the other line
because the other line is more risky so
I start with this move okay but now in
this case I will show you to take he
takes Bishop f4 c6 now when he plays c6
ultimate goal here is to play Bishop f5
for black because in this kind of
structure his Bishop is the worst piece
light square Bishop on c8 is the worst
piece here okay and he would like to get
rid of this bishop okay exchange it for
your bishop okay because he doesn't he
doesn't have that many squares to go to
so you'll see now you that's why when he
goes here you go Queen CQ will make a
couple of more moves you'll see why you
go here see it looks a little bit
strange because it looks like this
diagonal is really open for the bishop
but then look good squares to put this
bishop on you don't want to put it here
you don't want to put it here you cannot
put it here and what is the bishop going
to do here on g4 so it looks like really
this bishop is great right it's got all
the scoping but this is a bad piece for
him and the key is it's considered if
black can accomplish exchanging the
light square bishop with your bishop
it's equal position okay so these
positions if we take out the bishops now
black has absolutely no problems okay
but your goal is to prevent that okay
your goal is to prevent exchange of the
dark square bishop for black
okay any questions about this
I'm sorry lights you have to prevent you
from exchanging the light square bishop
I'm sorry yes
b6 we can see six I know but do as soon
as you play b6 your words in this
position because you created a big
weakness here so I will develop I can
just develop and you just you always
going to have some problem with this
point because the pile is half open you
know I can double up my looks as soon as
you touch the b-pawn block is worse even
if you exchange the bishop and
everything is just going to be you know
uncomfortable you know like look you go
here I'll just show you take take you
can just play a tree to stop this night
from coming in and now you have all this
kind of this kind of ideas you jump in
with this it's so easy to play rook c8
putting pressure it plays by itself you
know the moves they play by itself
that's why okay all right now so you go
Bishop d3 now he goes 9b d7 I'm going to
show you a very very cool idea here for
white rook e8 castle now after you
castle you have a very strong thread a
thread that will give you basically a
winning position you will win some
serious material here so here he needs
to be very careful because this trap
it's not it's not no one that much okay
so let's say your opponent just makes a
move like this bad move do you see the
idea now okay we have one person who
knows this idea did you see this in a
book or oh just you just saw it did you
see the whole sequence
well okay well let's give for everyone a
couple of minutes to think about we'll
go over it there is a little bit more
into it but but I think you probably
have the right move here so let's think
about it white makes a move and suddenly
he has like a serious advantage here
very very serious advantage here
hahaha ok ok it's very unexpected
suddenly you if you make this move your
opponent would be like where this come
from
it will be a total shock I've seen this
I've done this before and I've seen you
know in real games this idea
so
okay Julian wait wait wait just eat your
food first
okay next class I'll have something very
difficult Knight d5 II Knight e5 95
would be a normal move but it wouldn't
be winning or anything the move you make
it's actually will turn the tables it
will give white a winning advantage
winning advantage yes I mean still
technical but like you'll be up up
exchange the worst line you will be up
in exchange for no reason so basically
you'll be up to pawns
okay any ideas yes excellent correct
that your idea 95 now if it takes Bishop
c7 you see that fine gold lecture I did
some time ago but I keep mine over the
same tracks oh okay just hit me what you
were thinking about like looking on the
kingside I couldn't see anything
yeah the Queen kind of stuck there back
there yeah yeah you want to do this and
also you have this thread too but let's
say you go through cafe this is the idea
let's say he sees your thread he doesn't
want his Queen to get trapped what do
you do now because ninety seven it's not
good here he goes Ruby
okay if you have the move raise your
hand yes what's the move aha correct
c7 attacking the Queen Queen has to go
here right no squares to go to and now
we go ninety six shopping the Queen he
has to take it no choice and guess what
the rook is trapped now so you win
exchange no compensation
very cool trap okay that you could win a
lot of games with Knight to b5 very
strong yes hi excellent sir it's a real
real example here and you 2070 right and
you were what at that time 1600 1800
excellent I've seen this happen a lot
this is a pretty common idea it not only
plays h6 I mean there are other moves
also he can try to play if against a5
also this works
a5 they play sometimes to stop this
again same idea ok ok my next question
now for a moment let's turn the board
and let's say you playing block here you
see the threat how are you going to stop
it what you going to do to stop threat
in fact this move is just a very natural
move yes a six year but a six would be
like really trying to stop it but but it
does weaken your dark squares okay it
does weaken your dark squares so I'm not
absolutely sure about a six the main
move here you the reason you go 9b d7
rook e8 because you want to clear this
square for your night okay because your
knight actually wants to go to a fade so
your Bishop is some point can get out
and at some point your knight can jump
in here on g6 okay so this Knight f8 is
the the best move for black to stop
against the thread a6 is a way to stop
it but then you create further
weaknesses okay now now in this position
we don't have the other idea that we
discussed earlier with f3 for but now
we're going to switch back to the
minority attack
okay so minority attack starts with this
move rook p1 threatening to play b4 b5
so he's got to do something he's got to
do something okay now I place a 5 trying
to control the square now you play a3
controlling the before square okay
now you're going to be controlling this
square
now it goes 96 attacking your Bishop
Bishop g3
now we'll just ideas well Matt this fire
is a possible move
you could try there but even if you go
here and take my bishop I just take that
with a pawn
so I'm fine absolutely fine here so they
go sometimes we should be six here and
now you start the minority attack okay
the reason they call minority because
you attack with two pounds versus three
okay that's the minority yes
Bishop c4 you can but 95 kind of loses
the temple maybe because you can never
take because of pawn takes you lose this
h7 pawn see I have double attack I have
two pieces attacking on this pawn so
Knight Bishop g4 loses normally it's not
a good idea to play Bishop g4 in this
position sometimes you can you actually
I should say this way you could play
Bishop g4 sometimes if you're going to
be able to go here and here okay if
you're going to be able to do that then
yes it's okay got it so it goes here now
now we start a minority attack he takes
we take he takes we take Bishop e6 or d7
doesn't matter
you play b5 and what's going to happen
after you get a position like this he's
he has a weakness see when we had this
here he doesn't have a weakness right
it's absolutely fine but if you can
accomplish the minority attack no matter
how you exchange your pawns with his
pawns he is going to have at least one
weakness
okay in some cases is going to have two
weaknesses okay two weaknesses for
example if for example let's do this so
let's say he goes here we go here he
goes here
just showing you this is not necessarily
a very good line for black but now how
many weaknesses you see for black one
two right two potential weaknesses so
for him it's important to exchange the a
pounds so at least he can air one
weakness okay and it's no one especially
in the Russian chess school they train
you with one weakness if you play a
perfect defence you should be able to
hold but what do you know when opponent
has one weakness what do you need to do
to win a game you know when you have a
position like this excellent very good
that's it that's the idea you should
know when opponent has one weakness your
goal is to try to create the second one
second second weakness okay so this it
would be hard to win by itself because
it's not like oh I'm just going to
attack attack and win the pawn that's
not going to happen because it's equal
amount of pieces so you're always going
to attack is always going to defend and
his pieces are placed not very bad so
you know they're kind of close to the
pawn enough
so you're not going to be able to win
this pawn okay in some point you have to
try to create a second weakness okay so
remember that when opponent is one
weakness you establish the control of
that weakness you've it's fixed right
you think about how I create a second
weakness
okay second weakness is very important
you create the second weakness then you
have good chance okay so remember that
yes
c6 pawn is weak it's a backward pawn we
call this a backward pawn because it's
not protected by another pawn see and
now the C file is open if you can attack
on something multiple times that is a
weak pawn if this part was protected by
a pawn
then you can attack with so many pieces
but you cannot take but now we can
attack bring the rook in and we can try
to attack so which room is very
important to play here for white this
small is almost instantly almost always
you have to play this move here in this
kind of position yes
94 perfect yes night is coming in now
he's trying to defend passively keep
continue
95 excellent and now you don't
necessarily want to play rock fc-1 here
okay because you're just going to attack
but you want to get your Knights in
first okay then you want to get this
night in then you want to get the rukon
a seven then you want to put this one
here you don't necessarily want to
because if you just attack that's like a
standard thing everyone does they just
put and nothing really happens because
you can put everything you have on see
you're not going to win the six pawn
anyway so it's better for you try to
activate your pieces okay so you go 95
route B 795 rook FP one domination
complete domination here or white great
so this is how you play against the
Queens gambit declined opening okay so
if they play now Queens gambit declined
if you play d4 they do this now you know
what to do because we went over the both
both scenarios here okay scenario one
more common one Knight f6 because again
the setup you play they're not going to
be anticipating it so much because and
remember don't take on d5 okay and the
night goes on e - okay the night goes
only to setup ok Petrossian setup and we
also you know when over the conspire of
game against bharwa so this is how you
want to play okay Knight G - he goes
here Queen goes on C - and you castle
and then you go - okay b1 and you play
b4 b5 that's what you want to do so if
it goes here in this ending this line
with a knight only 2 F 3 e for setup ok
F 3 F or and don't forget the important
move here you may think that you're
ready to play E for here but you have to
play this move first because in other
lines that we went over that your Center
is not going to be a solid so what is
the correct move rook to d1 excellent
first you play this move and now you're
ready to play e4 and e5 h 6
take take efore and threatening to play
five and if it takes we have the default
pom protected okay so this is the main
line that I want to go over again one
more time with you g v e5 + f4 opening
up their file we will know how to take
just in case let's say he plays this
move let's say you think okay I'm not
going to worry about it I'm not going to
take this one is pretty much losing now
why what can you do now why you think
this move is pretty much losing now
yes excellent f5 and the threat is you
cannot take because we have it defended
twice and now we're going to go f6 and
the queen is going to jump in on g6 okay
so it's very strong you see the spot
this this is pretty much over now for
him then you can go 93 so let's say he
goes here
you put the night on g3 you can consider
doubling up the rooks and push f6
strengthen serious strength in the
center and this will give you the space
for your pieces
you